can i join the prime minister in his
comments about windrush uh and can i pay
tribute to everyone who is serving and
has served in our armed forces
can i also pay tribute to everyone
standing for election tomorrow in
particular the plucky conservative
candidate for wakefield
he's standing even though his own
colleagues think he's so useless they
held a vote of no confidence in him
just
[Applause]
does the prime minister hold any
personal interest
in seeing if the public will vote for a
tory that even his own side don't think
is up to it
well mr speaker i have absolutely no
doubt uh that the people of this country
and the people of wakefield people of
tibetan and hollister would much rather
vote uh for a solid conservative
government
for a labor party there are enablers and
acolytes in the liberal democrats mr
speaker the chameleons the karma
when the leader of the labour party
hasn't even got the gumption mr speaker
to speak out against the rail strikes
for the people in the north of this
country up and down there's no
absolutely unbelievable silence from the
leader of the labour party mr speaker
[Applause]
he's obviously not been to wakefield
recently
he's crashed the economy he's put
everybody's tax up the last story sent
up to wakefield being convicted of a
sexual assault that's not much of a
pitch prime minister
talking of people not up to the job
whilst the transport secretary spends
his time working on his spreadsheet
tracking the prime minister's
unpopularity
thousands of families have had their
holiday flights cancelled it takes
forever to review your driving license
or passport and now we've got the
biggest rail strike in 30 years if he is
[Applause]
both sides let's calm down we've only
just started
the problem is he'll go on forever and
nobody wants i sure you
whoever's speaking or asking questions
here's stammer
if he's genuine about preventing strikes
will the prime minister tell this house
how many meetings he or his transport
secretary have had with rail workers
this week to actually stop the strikes
[Applause]
mr speaker this is this is the
government that loves the railways that
invests in the railways
not 96 billion pounds we're putting into
the integrated railway plan building not
just i'm proud of bill crossfire by the
way mr speaker and we're going to build
northern powerhouse well but what we've
got to do is modernize our railways and
it is a disgrace when we are planning to
make sure that you don't have ticket
offices that sell fewer than one ticket
every hour mr speaker but he yesterday
had 25
labour mps
out on the picket line
out on the picket line to fight the
obstructions
i want to hear the proudest answer even
if you don't
i think you ought to show some respect
for the prime minister prime minister
out on the 25
and and the shadow deputy leader out on
the picket line uh mr speaker backing
the strikers mr speaker while we back
the strivers
mr speaker i'm surprised he's giving me
advice about my team if i do need advice
let's say about a hundred thousand pound
job at the foreign office i will ask him
for recommendation
and there you mr speaker
there you have it the prime minister of
this country and his transport secretary
haven't attended a single meeting held a
conversation or lifted a finger to stop
these strikes
but i did know that on monday they did
find time to go to a lavish ball where
the prime minister sold a meeting with
himself for 120 000 pounds
if there's money coming his way he's
there
he's nowhere to be seen
so rather than blame everyone else why
doesn't he do his job
get round the table and get the trains
running